it is May 29 2023 and you're watching
the code report if you're a poor person
from a third world country I have an
incredible opportunity for you you look
into this orb so I can Harvest a mutable
biometric data from your eye holes it
doesn't hurt I promise in exchange I
give you some of this shiny
cryptocurrency that some rich dudes in
San Francisco created out of thin air
with zero economic effort it's called
World coin and its goal is to scan a
billion eyeballs over the next few years
to create a global identity platform and
payment Network and no this isn't the
plot of a Black Mirror episode it's a
real project that just raised 115
million dollars and already has over a
million users it's co-founded by the
benevolent AI King Sam Altman and is
backed by a bunch of VCS like Andreessen
Horowitz which is behind many other
crypto projects like Alchemy coinbase
and Solana and even Sam bankman freed as
an early investor in fact you may have
already seen people wearing these World
coin t-shirts walking around your
village putting these weird balls in
people's faces these are your friendly
World coin operators and every time they
scan an eyeball they get some crypto
it's an ingenious business model it has
all the same Ponzi nomics of your
favorite over cryptocurrencies but is
hacking humans to do the actual physical
labor of collecting and processing
biometric data the way it works is it
takes a bunch of images of your iris
which like a fingerprint is unique to
every human which is then used to verify
your personhood so you can start using
worldcoin for everyday transactions the
actual images in biometric data itself
is deleted from the orb so there's no
reason to worry about your privacy the
technology is actually quite transparent
they explain in great detail how the orb
is manufactured and some of the source
code is available on GitHub ultimately
it's just a machine that can establish
proof of personhood but why would we
need a proof of personhood protocol well
the main reason is the rise of
artificial intelligence and the need to
differentiate between man and machine
when it comes to financial systems it
can protect against civil attacks which
is named after a book about a lady with
multiple personality disorder where one
person assumes the identity of multiple
accounts to game the system that can be
a problem in crypto but is not really an
issue in traditional banking the bigger
problem is that AI tools like deep fakes
and voice cloning can create digital
clones of people from their internet
presence and that's why it's more
important than ever that the people who
run these AI AI companies provide us
with a global digital passport to keep
us safe from these AI monstrosities that
they created it's not about money it's
all about making the world a better
place the world coin Foundation is the
initial Steward of the protocol but is
intended to become a public open source
Network owned by everybody and it could
potentially evolve into a global
Universal basic income which we're
definitely going to need after gpt5
takes all our jobs for good that sounds
awesome and I can't wait to just hang
out all day and play video games but
worldcoin has a long uphill battle ahead
of itself the MIT technology review
released a scathing article last year
that alleged deceptive marketing
practices among a variety of other
issues and then you already have a black
market emerging in China for Iris data
to exploit the world coin system the
biggest issue though is that people are
resistant to look into the orb the orb
is your friend you must look into the
orb what's funny though is that most of
us have already given up all of our
facial biometric data to companies like
apple meta and Tick Tock in a far less
transparent way after the ore verifies
that you're a human your identity is
added to a list of verified humans then
the world Coin App generates a zero
knowledge proof to prove your identity
without revealing any of your secret
information in theory you could be
totally Anonymous on worldcoin but many
are skeptical and think it's just laying
the groundwork for a world currency that
will be implemented by the upcoming One
World Government after the alien
invasion of 2027 at which point they'll
no longer scan our eyeballs but instead
he's far more reliable alien probes oh
my God I just cracked the code you can't
spell probe without orb I could be wrong
here but just to be safe I'm gonna stick
with Monero for all my Anonymous crypto
needs this has been the code report
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one